guillaume perrault sous ces affichages
de fermeté quand même on a vu que le
gouvernement était en train de un peu
reculé sur les évaluations en cp par
exemple c'est un exemple mais escape a
un double discours quand même entre bon
on dit aux enseignants ce qu'il faut
faire et puis en même temps on fait des
aménagements
après de l'est certains il est certain
qu'il y a une force de résistance
d'inertie au ministère de l'éducation
nationale qui est extrêmement forte et
sellami il n'y a pas de mission plus
difficile que d'être ministre de
l'éducation nationale et de garrigue
arrive pour le moment pas notre point de
vue c'est bon pour le moment il fait le
mieux possible à la tête d'un du
ministère le plus difficile qui soit
voilà alors peut-être qu'en effet il
agit du lest sur certains sujets pour
avancer sur ce qui lui paraît
prioritaire fait des compromis en
fonction des rapports de force des
alliés bref il fait de la politique
voilà